francis had two people accidentally shot
on a movie set by a prop gun we need
help immediately oh bonanza creek ranch
come on that is the panicked voice of a
crew member calling 9-1-1 from the set
of this movie thursday afternoon the
director and cinematographer shot by
star alec baldwin we need some help our
director and our cameraman is
camerawoman has been shot are they going
to take him to the road so was it loaded
with a real bullet or one yeah
they were filming a western in santa fe
new mexico baldwin's gun appearing to
misfire helena hutchins shot in the
chest she died a short time later in
hospital director joel souza standing
behind her hit in the shoulder not
fatally
shares came down said on another set
there was live
a live gun discharge reports from
sources on the set claim there had been
two misfires from the gun just a week
earlier that gun apparently handed to
baldwin on thursday by the assistant
director say court documents both
thought it was free of live ammunition
baldwin tweeting a link to this story
emphasizing that very point insiders say
crew were extremely concerned that they
had complained about a lack of safety
protocols around guns some even
apparently walking off in protest
allegedly replaced by new members in an
effort to keep the production on track
this as audio comes to light of the gun
handler apparently expressing her lack
of experience when talking about her
previous movie
you know i was really nervous about it
at first and i almost didn't take the
job because i wasn't sure if i was ready
but doing it like it went really
smoothly
hollywood is familiar with tragedy on
set brandon lee son of star bruce lee
killed by a gun nearly 30 years ago
while shooting the crow that led to a
range of safety protocols being brought
in
and so the big question in hollywood
were those protocols being followed if
so how could this have happened why was
their live ammunition on set why were
the crew so close at the time so many
questions to be answered as this police
investigation continues and hollywood
comes to terms with the tragic loss of
one of its rising stars phil lavelle al
jazeera los angeles